[Music]
what's up everybody happy weekend we've
got a bunch of packages here that have
been building up a bunch of books and
some other things so it's time for
another male time with advocacy annina
before we open these if you guys want to
send me anything that's going to be
potentially featured on a future episode
of male time and get on the channel come
on your products send me some love the
address we're going to link up in the
description below to send me stuff and
you might be on the next edition and get
on the channel so but that being said
Nina sorting it out okay there you go
open it up first one here comes your
tongue oh it's Christmas this is cart do
you reckon hope these find you well
inclusive some believe Mars bars oh it's
is Jeremy Jeremy I met at sage summit in
Chicago and you followed me around
everywhere I mean we had a blast
imagining boots we need food let's get
food and he said it in UK talents
believe Mars bars who's gonna send me
some so let's let's see the believe Mars
but wow look at these can we look at
that interesting yeah believe I loved we
can't eat these we got to see these what
you just have one look it has a UK flag
on it to hear me took one look you took
one over there look at you sniffing did
you guys see that if she snuck it over
there
[Music]
love it's a mars bar it's a mars bar to
sender stand can we keep one today what
do you think guys should we let me eat
one today pave the way to get the way to
next we can see and then why jeremy has
his carcass is blue eyed son and so he's
got these cool cards I like this one
look at that happy birthday Merry
Christmas congratulations these are cool
and we can check them out the white Sun
co at UK I love it Thank You Jeremy you
rock okay that's Nina where we opening
here first when you touch testable you
touch it you open it break you buy
million-dollar blog there's a card for
you okay I think I'm in this book I did
an interview I didn't guarantee the
google hangouts here am I in that age 95
ha there it is can we see Evan
Carmichael dear Evan the million our
blog is fight like this card this is a
this is some pics top of the cars become
better known for what you do the middle
er blocks from here thank you so much
for being involved with a book i really
appreciate you can find your interview
on page 95 then closed copy your diction
doing flaps running left so you know
you'd like to read post your interview
let me know so that's version all the
best awesome very cool thank you thank
you thank you look at that i'm in about
a book go check it out building our blog
gimme the bucks eNOS been looking for
some new book series so okay rah Nina
muscles oh this one has sticky notes all
right there we go success 10 10 for
living achieve your goals and say
successful what do we got I like I like
how there's like these little sticky
notes that tell me what page is supposed
to read Oh
stop barry's the best I'm really like
the block us from reaching our true
potential and later in life I like that
the struggle blockage imagine if I had
to I think I hang on to be so bad my
hangar be so bad she wants you on the
legalism I think this one holds people
back for Entrepreneurship lack of
confidence very cool success 10 10 g'day
Evan wow look at this full lon full page
letter here I'm so excited to see your
answer my question my recent business
Q&A legal is that was before and then
you get a million of these things into
you I've included some sticky notes into
sections I think relate to you most and
the belief team philosophies I love it
alright I'm going to check it out
Melanie thank you for that feeling the
love much appreciated oh this is from
junior eyes jason j reyez fonseka means
a team of a shirt look at that this is
American Apparel 50 pitbull Jerry's only
makes good quality teemo's a champ and I
playing league of legends there you go
look at that team oh I like to thank you
Jason another book The Book of the bud
good luck we gotta read law of
attraction and action Evan thank you for
inspiring me to hashtag believe in
myself jonathan webster all right look
at that very cool i'll check this out
for the next three months and i will
spend any time with you you know sorry
three books hopping over the rabbit hole
when we go how much return failure to
success oh Anthony scored mucci I'm
interviewing him on my channel into
action by Tony Robbins so this is this
must be a mock-up this is like a
uncorrected proof okay cool look at that
very cool I'm going to check that
he's going to be on a he's going to be
on my channel soon thank you google in
England the gratitude guy is there a
note cuz I know hold on gratitude guy so
I do this I do grant we live stream
everyday 9am on the channel on my live
channel we can link that up so you can
check it out this is cool Thank You Evan
Jacob the gratitude guide your gateway
to a happy and abundant life oh look at
this holy cow this is a cute oh this is
ryan holiday this is ryan's new book
cool the daily stoic I don't know if
this is actually out yet I think they've
ever come out meditation 366 meditations
on wisdom perseverance and the art of
living it's something to do every day
it's a daily every day of the year
something to think about oh oh this is a
easy to read maybe I could read that
it's only one page of thing yeah cool I
don't think this is out yet oh I like
the color thoughts on pork market to
that that's cool i like that all right
Thank You Ryan I'm gonna check it out
but Nina might check it out first any
something to read if you want Nia to
read your book on the subway ride to her
office and make sure it's short chapters
one chapter per day yes ok last one last
one here it is here it is here it is we
got us the gift box something from
hungry who is this from what is this
thing okay so this is heart with jewels
on it from the Venn checks go art
gallery yo recom g y ou R Y calm and
it's sign Yuri I don't remember what the
story is about this I feel really bad so
they put
time into making this and make sure you
give me a story I feel really bad but
it's unique thank you guys are the fun
for sending the books and the belief
chocolate bars and teacher and gifts and
cards and hope a foot yeah neither not
reminded of chocolate bars in my seat
that if you guys sent food you know
Mina's gonna want to eat it ASAP so you
like it there's not this water yeah but
it doesn't believe hashtag believe I
want to save it look at this lunch guys
oh my gosh patek believe I don't know
I'll put it on my shelf okay fine open
it I'm fine repeated thing okay okay
okay yes this is it you got oh you got
to break it in you got to break it in
half and then what and then Cheers okay
come on time just like believe thank you
everybody hope you have an amazing end
to the weekend thank you for the gifts
send me more stuff idaho put an open it
next time we believe in you we hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
i'll see you soon for see you soon